[music]
[applause]
>> I'm Mike Allen, co-founder of Axios.
Thank you to the
Google I/O team for making these
conversations possible. Demis Hassabis
started as a chess savant and a gamer.
Now co-founder and CEO of Google
DeepMind where he's on the front lines
of both the scientific race
and the business race for AI.
DeepMind's landmark AI breakthroughs
include AlphaGo and AlphaFold which
solved the 50-year grand challenge of
protein structure.
For cracking that code, Demis was
awarded the Nobel Prize in chemistry.
The Economist last month put Demis on
the cover as a Greek god complete with
tunic
in a pantheon of the titans who are
shaping all of our future. He's even
been knighted. The mind behind DeepMind,
Sir Demis Hassabis, welcome to
Dialogues.
>> [music]
>> Hey Mike, good to see you. Thank you so
much for doing this.
>> Yeah, thanks for doing it.
So Demis, yesterday at your
keynote where you got by the way big
applause and even whoops for
announcing that the Gemini for science
which is one of your favorites. But you
left us
with the ultimate cliffhanger. You said
when we look back at this time
I think we will realize we were standing
in the foothills of the singularity.
Take us one layer deeper. What do you
think is going to happen? What do you
hope is going to happen?
Yeah, I thought people seem to pick up
on that line specifically and
yes, so it was kind of expected, but
it's great to be able to expand on it a
little bit. So,
I'm talking a lot about obviously AGI
being on the horizon. I think we are
only a few years away now from from
the full version of that. And the
singularity is a kind of good word I
think to describe the era that is
precipitated by a technology like AGI
arriving on on on the scene.
And partly it's because
it's going to be so transformative. I
think the most important invention ever
that it's hard to make many predictions
beyond that horizon because it will
change so much. So, and I think this
year with the agents
agentic systems that we're all seeing
and using, I think we can start feeling
it now. And that's what I was sort of
meaning by that. When we look back, I
think in 5-10 years time, I think we'll
sort of see it like, "Oh, yes, you know,
2026, 2027 is sort of when it was when
it was starting." And I love that we're
starting to feel it. Expand on that a
little bit. How do you feel it? Well, I
think all of you I mean, I've been
feeling it just by using our own
coding systems and coding agents and
just by coding things even like little
game prototypes in my in my spare one or
two hours in the small hours of the
morning which would have taken, you
know, 6 months before. And I just think
that kind of acceleration is very
interesting to see. I think we're seeing
it in areas of science.
Obviously with AlphaFold which was
a few years ago now, but almost every
branch of science AI being applied to.
And I'm also seeing the the speed at
which we're making advances in things
like Isomorphic Labs for drug discovery.
So, I think taking that all together and
using the current looks sort of looking
at the current progress of the of the
foundation models and the chatbot
systems and things like Omni.
All of that taken together is just
astounding progress, I would say. Yeah,
and based on the markers you set over
the years, I feel like we're kind of
right on schedule. Uh you say a few
years, what is your latest marker? Well,
I I feel like it's, you know, I've been
saying recently around 2030, you know,
plus or minus a year, I think is a kind
of reasonable estimate from what I'm
seeing now. So, 2029 to 2031. Mhm.
So, DeepMind's original mission
statement was solve intelligence. How
are we doing?
Well, I think we're we're we're doing
pretty well. So, our original statement
was, you know, step one, solve
intelligence, step two, use it to solve
everything else. And I think that was
pretty prescient, you know, that's what
we felt AGI would be is
a general-purpose technology that could
help I was thinking more about science
and medicine specifically and our, you
know, increasing our understanding of
how the world works around us. That's
been always been my passion, as you
know. And I think we are on the on the
on the cusp of that now. In the lifetime
of the builders and searchers in this
room and watching us around the world,
you think intelligence will be solved?
Yes, well, I I mean, look, solved is
it's just a a neat term, what does it
actually mean? But I I I'm what I meant
by that was building
AGI and I think, you know, we're a few
years away. So, that's that would be the
first step to me. And you think with
AGI, different people will talk about it
different ways, but I think you're one
of the people that thinks that there
will be a moment and that we will know.
Well, I know, I think it's that's not
the case. I think it will be it's going
to be a gradual improvement. I think
that's what we're seeing, pretty
probably a pretty fast improvement, but
that I have a particular test in mind,
which is
I call kind of like the Einstein test.
So, you know, imagine you had a
knowledge cutoff of one of these
leading, you know, frontier models of
1901, would it be able to come up with
his incredible sort of insights and
discoveries that he did in 1905
including special relativity, right?
Could it Could it Could a system come up
with those insights and breakthroughs?
And I think today systems clearly can't,
but I think
I don't see why in the future they won't
be able to. So, that's the sort of
creativity or leap of insight that I'm
still looking for from these systems for
it to be full AGI.
Lots of buzz among tech writers in press
park right here at Google IO about
Google having its groove back.
Brian Chen of the New York Times posted
yesterday how Google is starting to win
the AI race. If you win, it will be why?
What is the Google edge? And what
changed?
Look, I think it's it's sort of weird
this you know, this sort of idea of like
we're back and then we're winning and
then we're not back and it's all The
thing is that at least the three
frontier labs and and actually the whole
of the frontier, it's the most ferocious
competition there's ever been, I would
say in tech history, maybe in corporate
history. So,
there's that going on, very capable
brilliant people in all the
organizations.
Each trying to push as hard as they can
on the research and the breakthroughs. I
think we're doing [snorts] really well
for what we need to do
both in terms of the underlying
technologies. We have a kind of broader
research branch than I think
the other labs have. We've always had
that. I think that's what gives us our
innovative capacity, you know, to invent
the next breakthroughs.
You see now new models that are coming
out, our 3.5 flash pro coming soon.
We're very happy with the with the
progress that we're making on the
underlying models. We also have all our
generative media models, you know, Omni
being the latest.
So, that's going well. Where I think
things are going extremely well is on
the consumer side. So, applying I think
that's what the really big leap has been
for us in the last year is streamlining
our tech stack, actually almost
rewriting it from from the ground up to
be AI first and now agent first. You
know, that's a big change for a
incredible engineering organization like
Google that serves billions of users
every day on multiple product surfaces
on our incredible engineering stack
and but that has to adapt so that you
can ship the model and the goodness of
the latest models directly into all of
those products at massive massive scale.
And I think we've got that down really
well now, better than any of the other
you should say big tech companies. And I
think you're starting to see that in the
progress we're making with the adoption
of Gemini app, you know, 900 million
monthly users now, incredible growth
there that we're seeing
and also things like AI mode in search,
unbelievably popular and and incredibly
useful I think sort of version of AI for
information seeking. So, I think if you
look across our surfaces and what we're
doing with our models, especially the
small efficient models that are still
very powerful. So, that's really
important for our internal use cases
because we got to serve billions of
users, but it's also very important for
some of our big enterprise customers as
well. So, I think when you take a look
at that at Aggrega and then you also can
see the the advantage we have being full
stack all the way from the the the chips
to the data centers to cloud to frontier
lab to um
billion user
products
that have AI embedded in them. We have I
think we're the only organization in the
world that has that full stack and we're
continually trying to optimize that
feedback loop so that they all feed into
each other. Do you think you will win?
Well, I don't I think we're going to be
one of the big winners of the of the
era.
>> Well, I I I I don't know. You know, it's
I don't really see it like that in terms
of like, you know, win win to what
exactly. So,
I think the AI era is going to be
immense. It's going to be unbelievable
amount of uh new uh opportunities
created, uh new uh economic uh progress
made, and we got to make sure that we're
one of the key players in that new
uh new post-AGI world. And I think we're
incredibly well positioned for that. And
as to how many players there'll be, my
guess is a handful,
um given how powerful the technology is.
But actually, stepping back from that,
what I always say is, although we're
ferociously, you know, competing in this
kind of race, we've actually all the
leaders of the frontier labs need to uh
think about, and they are thinking about
um the bigger picture of the
responsibility to the world, you know,
as we bring this unbelievable technology
into the world. We want it to be for the
benefit of everyone and the benefit of
humanity. And there's something bigger
than all of us and the competition is
remembering, you know, we got to take
these final steps in a careful,
thoughtful way and make sure that we're
building it with safety and security in
mind, as well as
uh um enabling all of the amazing good
use cases that we hope to see.
Thomas, picking up on your word
opportunity, and the 5,000 students and
professional developers here on campus
are living proof of that. Yeah. And yet
a lot of America doesn't see it, feel
it. From page of today's Wall Street
Journal, the AI lash building, right,
American rebellion. Eric Schmidt getting
booed. Why is that happening and what
can you do about it?
Well, I think a lot of the ways that
some of the, you know, let's say my
peers are talking about this, I don't
really agree with. I don't really agree
with the the the the the the style of
communication, but also um some of the
substance, too. So, what I would say,
the way I'm looking at it is, there's
going to be no doubt huge amount of
change. So, something this
transformative, you know, it's I've I've
been on record saying if you want to try
and quantify it, it's going to be 10
times the impact of the Industrial
Revolution, maybe 10 times faster. So,
over a decade instead of a century. And
that might be an underestimate. Probably
is.
>> 10 times the impact and 10 times faster.
>> Yeah, so you can think of it as 100x the
entire the Industrial Revolution. Maybe
an underestimate. So, that's huge. But,
what I say about that, the future's not
written. This very uncertain, you know,
are there more jobs going to be created?
ones? We don't know. Nobody knows. None
of these experts, so-called experts,
know. And the future's to be written
actually by the next generation. I'm
actually very excited
when I talk to students and when I go to
places like we just came back from
earlier this year from the India AI
summit and the youth of India so excited
about what they can do, what these tools
will enable them to do, build companies,
build applications, um compete at the
global scale. So, this technology is
actually democratizing opportunities for
what you can build. What would have
taken a team of 10, 50 experts to build,
maybe you know, a smart kid in their
garage can can build it themselves. So,
I So, then when I think back to the era
I grew up in with computers and home
computers and and then there was the
internet and the amount of opportunities
that then created for for
for kids of the day, students of the
day, who had grew up native with that
technology to actually go on and build
the future that we see today. And I
think that will happen again with
those the next generation that's going
to grow up AI native. And I think for
the next 10 years at least, and it's
hard to see beyond that, it's they're
going to be superpowered. As long as
they're technically trained enough and
then they bring creativity and sort of
taste and judgment, these kinds of
skills to the table. I think that's
going to be the next era. So, I'm
actually very optimistic about human
ingenuity to find amazing ways to use
and we're seeing that all the time to
use these new tools. Your hunch would be
net more jobs or you can't even say
that. I think there will be
changes to the job market as always
there is with any new revolution.
But I think I don't see why there
wouldn't be more opportunities. Maybe
it'll be more like creating startups,
you know, one or two person startups.
More entrepreneurial skills will be
needed cuz you have these incredible
creative tools. So it's it's there's
going to be changes, but I think overall
it will be it will be better.
And then the other thing I would say on
the backlash is that I think it's
incumbent on the field our field, the AI
field and industry to show the
unequivocal benefits more clearly and
more concretely. And that's what we try
to do with our AI for science work.
And applying AI to advancing science and
medicine. So that's why I spent my whole
career working on using these AI tools
for things like AlphaFold as you
mentioned and drug discovery. And I
think there's so many areas of science
that AI can be applied to and we're
trying to do that material science,
mathematics, energy sources.
So that's what I think we need to show
more of and I hope our
our
other peer organizations do more of as
well. Now Demis taking your point about
style of communication, you rather
follow Greek gods on the cover of the
Economist. You're proudly a scientist.
You're not a doomer. You're not an
accelerationist.
Why do some AI leaders talk about the
negatives of AI? How does that help
them?
Well, I'm I'm I'm I'm in the middle. So
I call myself a cautious optimist.
Cautious optimist. So I'm optimistic.
Obviously I'm optimistic otherwise I
wouldn't have been doing this for 30
years that the benefits are going to far
outweigh the the negatives with
something like AI. As long as we take
our time, we give ourselves the time a
society to get this next few years
right. We're talking about, you know,
the next hundred, maybe thousand years
of human
flourishing
if we get this right.
>> And all of us are living now. And and
and um
But we got there's a lot of challenges
to to get that right. So, we got to give
ourselves the time to do it rather than
just sort of racing to
to just get the next thing out. And I
think that's that's where
we've got to kind of put our attention
to and come together to discuss like the
bigger impacts that all of this work is
going to produce.
We have a treat.
A clip from The Thinking Game, a
remarkable documentary
about Demis and DeepMind filmed over
five years. We have a fascinating scene
from your old offices in London. This
was not rehearsed or recreated, totally
serendipitous. Cameras just happened to
be there. Let's watch.
Now we have a tool that can be used
practically by scientists. These people
asking us, you know, I've got this
protein involved in malaria or, you
know, some infectious disease. We don't
know the structure. Can we use AlphaFold
to to solve [music] it? We can easily
predict all known sequences in a month.
All known sequences in a month? Yeah,
easily. A billion, two billion. Um
And they're we
>> we just do [music] that? Yeah, we should
just do that with that. Well, we I mean
we Like now you Why don't we just do
that? Well, so that's one of the options
like we
you know, there's this We should just
what we should That's a That's a great
idea.
We should just run every protein in
existence.
And then release that. Why hasn't
someone suggested this before? Of course
[music] that's what we should do. Why
are we thinking about making a service
and then people submit their protein? We
just fold everything and then give it to
everyone in the world. Who knows how
many discoveries will be made from that?
So
>> [applause]
>> So, a quote
for the ages, an iconic moment, we saw
the DeepMind
working. Demis, when you said, "So, why
don't we do that? So, why don't we just
do that?"
Tell us what was in your DeepMind and
what was happening.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh so, look, this is this is the
that particular example, and actually
I'll just get back to your last question
as well about acceleration. This is the
type acceleration that we want, right,
in my opinion. So, you couldn't get any
more accelerations in a sense than what
I spent my whole career doing. I think
there are so many challenges facing
society today from disease to energy,
our environmental ecosystems, uh
you know, climate change. We need
technology like AI to come and help so
help us solve these other problems. And
um the number one, in my opinion, as I
said yesterday, is applying AI to
improving human health.
Um with AlphaFold protein protein
folding and predicting protein
structures is one of the critical pieces
of developing drugs uh to to help with
these diseases. Only one piece, but a
critical piece. And what was happening
there is I just sort of worked out
because AlphaFold was um literally in
that meeting because AlphaFold was so
accurate, but it's also um so fast. So,
it could fold a protein in a matter of
seconds. And then the you know, I knew
there were a couple couple hundred
million proteins known to science, and
just a back-of-the-envelope calculation,
I could fit
feel that if we put a certain amount of
computers on it, we could fold all of
them in a year. So, there was no need to
set up uh the normal way of doing this,
which is like a server and have people
submit their genetic sequences, that the
amino acid sequences of the protein they
they cared about, and then you'd go away
and fold it for a week and give them
back the structure. Um we could just put
all of it out there for free into the
world on a huge database uh run by the
European bio- bioinformatics institution
in Cambridge and just let everybody
around the world, all the researchers
around the world, access whatever uh
protein they wanted uh at this almost at
the at the speed of a Google search. So,
that to us felt like it was obvious to
me that was the biggest impact we could
do with this breakthrough. So,
I think that's an example of great
acceleration, but on the other hand, uh
I'm not in the camp of the the Pollyanna
camp of like, well, there's no risk
here. Let's let it rip. There's no
danger. Of course, when we're bringing
in something this momentous, you know,
as something like AGI, so what a new era
we're going into, a new you know, we
have to think that through very
carefully. And uh there are going to be
challenges and risks and there'll be
ways um which uh we can try and mitigate
that, but again, only if we give
ourselves enough time collectively to do
that.
The fact that cameras followed you for 5
years, the fact that you're willing to
let them in, you recognize that you're
on the frontier of something that will
shape humanity. It's hard to see
ourselves as others see us. What did you
learn from the documentary, the the
process, or actually watching it?
Well, I I actually I hate seeing myself
on camera, so it's it was a hard thing
to agree to, but it's like um
they they're the same film crew that did
the AlphaGo movie, if you if you some of
you have seen that for the AlphaGo
match, and they came along right at the
last minute to do that, and I thought it
was a really moving uh uh documentary
recording of like quite an important
moment in AI sort of modern AI history,
uh the big match we had against Lisa
Doll. It's just it's actually we just
celebrated the 10-year anniversary of
that. It's kind of unbelievable really.
In some ways, feels like a century has
gone by, in other ways, it feels like
yesterday. But, um
I I and then they proposed to to
basically be a kind of fly on the the
and we trusted them with that, and
um and they were you know, if they
happen to be around at key moments like
that one, it was kind of amazing they
happen to be in that meeting cuz then
they they come over every now and again
and record a few things. And one of the
reasons we agreed to do that is um we
felt that the the the the this is a
societal level uh transformation, this
technology. We felt that people would
want to know something about uh the
people behind it, what their motivations
were, why were they doing this, what do
we think the good that can come from it.
And uh and I hope that documentary shows
that. It seems to have gone down well,
and I think does portray they've done a
good job of portraying, you know, what
our motivations and passions are, things
like AI for science. Uh Demis, a quick
tour of your mind and world, simulations
and robotics. What's going on, and why
are simulations such a key uh milestone?
I think simulations are really
important. I've I've been sort of
enamored with simulations as long as
I've had with AI. In fact, the first the
first real professional thing I
programmed was Theme Park, uh this game
I wrote in the '90s, which was both AI
had AI in it, and it was a simulation
game, one of the first for both. It came
out in 1994. And um so, I've always seen
them as quite complementary. So, both in
the sense that uh you can use AI to
learn simulations about complex uh
phenomena. So, for example, our weather
next uh uh uh system that we showcased
yesterday that helps predict the paths
of hurricanes and other extreme weather
events much more quickly and and more
accurately than traditional systems.
Um but also, it can provide data for AI
systems. So, for example, we've been
using Genie, our kind of interactive 3D
uh model, to um test Waymo uh cars in
very unusual, one in a billion type
situations that you would never see in
the real world. So, for example, you
know, what if your the road you're
driving down a road and there's a forest
fire around you? Or,
um you know, a a plane a biplane has
done an emergency landing on the
motorway. Uh or an elephant appeared in
the road. These kind of things which
you're never going to see in your sort
of everyday training data, but you want
to know how is your system going to
react? Um and so, uh
you know, these types of simulations are
very useful for testing that. And if
your system doesn't do well there, you
can use it to generate more data that
you can learn from. Okay, this is going
to be your favorite question. Uh I know
you love to talk about the scientific
method. AI for science and health. And
you've talked about human health as the
ultimate use case for AI.
Yes. So, uh
I think that the AI is the ultimate tool
for science in the in the limit. It's
why I started this whole journey was to
um
try and as a scientist understand better
the world around us. And I felt that our
minds, you know,
we could use an incredible tool to help
even the smartest experts uh more
quickly navigate all the complexity of
the data that we collect and try and
find connections and insights and
structure in that data. And uh what
better tool than AI to do that? And I
think that's coming to fruition now. And
it's just a very very exciting time to
see the pace of science pick up in all
sorts of fields. Many fields where we've
been stuck for 30 40 years. Um like we
were with protein folding. And I think
we're going to see a lot of those um
uh breakthroughs over the next decade or
so.
AI in the real
world. What are some of the ways that
people are already feeling it and it's
part of the AI lash that they don't
realize it?
Well, I mean, we're using AI all the
time in pretty much every product that
we use. So, everything that from maps to
uh from our point of view, maps to Gmail
has now been enhanced and is in the
middle of being upgraded with AI. What I
hope to see is with the next generation
of assistants, so you saw us talk about
Gemini Spark yesterday, but also the
glasses, the smart glasses, is
eventually this will give us back time.
That's what I hope. I hope that the
smarter our AI assistants are,
the less admin we need to do, the less
time we actually need to spend with
with a lot of the technologies that are
kind of mundane and actually give us
time back to focus on what we think's
important, whether that's creativity,
our families,
and just connecting with other humans.
That's
I think in the next few years what I
hope will happen, but we can still stay
connected and get the information that
we need, you know, to do our jobs or
that that interests us, but more
conveniently at the time that we want
because we'll have an AI assistant
that's helping us manage all of that.
Look at all the keynote announcements
yesterday here at Google I/O.
Uh
the
uh keynote put a bow around a lot of it,
but it was also a lot
Excuse me, a lot to take in. You know,
Fried Axios had a great headline about
AI everywhere.
Hit pause and what's something from
these announcements that we should
remember, focus on?
I think the main thing is that that that
the
the agentic era is really here and I
think what we were really excited about
this this this
this I/O is how we're integrating that
across the the Google ecosystem. So,
with Workspace, with all of the things
that
people use every day and love, how is
that going to interact securely with an
agentic system? I think we've seen the
potential of agents, but I think we're
just scratching the surface of what they
can do.
>> [laughter]
>> Um from coding to all the way to like
managing your sort of admin load. I'm
very excited about all of those things.
And then just obviously the potential of
these world models to help in the real
world with things like
we know hopefully we'll be talking about
this next year, some big advances in
areas like robotics.
And responsibility. How does that how do
you think about that in your work? Does
it inhibit? Does it accelerate? How do
you think about it?
I think it's a critical it's not it's
not really about inhibiting or
accelerating. It's it's a critical part
of everything we do. You know when
you're working on this kind of
technology and you know we wish we've
been for a long time
and you're thinking about the
implications both obviously the enormous
amazing benefits that we're hoping for
but that comes with you know it's a dual
purpose technology. Those things can be
also repurposed by bad actors for
harmful ends. So those two things weigh
heavily on us
that or should do that are the forefront
and the frontier and understand that
both the negative and the positive
consequences of what this technology can
do.
And the last stop on our tour future
vision. Tell us
what you know is behind the curtain and
what we should be watching for in let's
say coming months.
Well the big thing that everyone's
working at the moment on is this idea of
self-improvement. So of course we're
seeing some sort of a slow version of
that with coding agents helping our own
engineers get better and more productive
with with coding.
The question is is like what's the next
level of that and I think coding and
mathematics are kind of quite special
cases because the outputs are
verifiable. You can verify whether
they're correct and you can also
generate as much synthetic
data as you want. Right? So
I think there's a evidence that this is
a kind of compounding flywheel. So, I
think that's a very interesting space
that all the leading labs are investing
heavily on.
Um and then I think the other area is
just to build the reliability and
robustness of these systems and
consistency really of um
uh how these systems work, uh tool use,
and instruction following, and make sure
that they're uh they they're reliable
over long-term plans. So, I think again,
that's going to be the next step change
for these things. Um and part of that is
making sure that they're uh robust and
safe and secure. Um I think the more
powerful these agents get, and the more
we kind of delegate tasks to them, um
the more we have to make sure from a
sort of cybersecurity standpoint,
they're doing exactly what we're
expecting them to do, and we can monitor
that, and um they're being done you
know, securely. Okay, so that's a good
framework to think about step changes.
And you pointed to consistency, right?
Like, what would our step change buckets
be for, say, 2026?
Well, consistency, we we shouldn't be
seeing um as we get closer to something
like AGI, we shouldn't be seeing systems
that are brilliant at certain things
when posed in certain ways, but they're
still tripped up uh if you uh
you know, present them with a simpler
problem, say, in mathematics, but you
you present it in a certain way that it
hasn't, you know, it's a little bit more
out of distribution. And uh I think that
shouldn't be the case for
uh an AGI system, a general
intelligence. You know, that's not the
case with human intelligence. Right? If
you're if you're good at one sort of uh
game or one kind of uh a task, and you
give it you give that person a strictly
simpler problem in the same sort of
domain, um they'll be able to solve that
problem, too. Right? But they won't be
this kind of jagged intelligence. I
think another big area that's missing,
and where we we're focusing on, too, is
continual learning. How do you have
systems that um learn after their
training, after they've been released
out into the wild? How can they adapt
and learn further? And that's also
related to personalization and making
sure that the systems are kind of
personalized to
to the extent that you want as the user
to
you know, your particular context. Last
one on the future. A year from now at
Google I/O 2027, what do you think we'll
be talking about? What will be the
centerpiece?
I think there'll be a lot more
uh
agents in the real world uh
kind of embedded in our workflows. I
think we're starting to see that now. I
think over the next year that will
mature.
So, I think that will be a huge thing
and I hope also there'll be big
advances in AI in the real world. So, I
would like I'm hoping we'll see some big
leaps forward in applying these kinds of
models that understand the world. Gemini
robotics, you know, the sort of robotics
model out there right now, but applied
to uh many different form factors in in
in robotics.
And
AI in the real world, I think something
you've talked about as an example
Hurricane Melissa. Mhm.
And and how AI can be used in weather
forecasting?
Yes, so that was one of the examples we
showed yesterday of of
incredible way that we can use AI in
simulation. So,
um
whether I think it's you know, it's a
very complicated dynamic system involves
solving a lot of equations in the
traditional way Navier-Stokes equations,
fluid dynamics. So, these kinds of
traditional systems take weeks to run
and
and they're kind of limited in how far
ahead they can look. And for a situation
like an extreme weather event like a
hurricane, you want to know and as we
showed in the video yesterday even a day
ahead of time
is very important for
emergency services and reducing the
damage
uh uh to human lives and also property
that these extreme weather events come
with. So, I think that's just one
example of the big strides we're making
with applying AI to learn simulations
from the available data rather than
directly programming the mechanics of a
simulation by hand.
So, your advice to your younger self in
an interview that you gave in connection
when you were awarded uh the Nobel
Prize, you said believe in your ideas
even though they can seem quite
outlandish. And you said you personally
had done that. How has AI made that even
more true?
You said having confidence in your ideas
from the very earliest stage makes all
the difference.
Well, I I think um
you need to have confidence in your
ideas on anything big if you're going to
have stand a chance of achieving it.
That's That's very clear.
Um but I also think that it's not really
just about confidence. It's also your
passion and um
your belief in how important that that
work is. So, when I talk about AI, for
example, obviously we're here today
where AI is the biggest thing that the
world's talking about. And I think that
we always imagined went back when we
started DeepMind in 2010 and before then
that that could happen. But I would have
also carried been still working on AI
now whether or not that had happened.
So, if it was still a more of a niche uh
you could say academic subject because I
think it was the most fascinating uh uh
problem and most important problem to be
working on. It's worked out. The timing
was right that that we thought back then
that it was a kind of 20-year mission.
We're sort of exactly on schedule. Um
but I would have been doing it anyway.
So, it's a little bit beyond confidence.
It's a sense of like almost obsession
with that problem and it being the right
problem and the most interesting problem
at least for my mind and the way that my
mind works and the passions that I had.
That was my expression of trying to
advance science um was to build this
amazing tool that was also an
interesting scientific artifact in of
itself. So what more of an interesting
thing could one spend your life and
career on? That's how I felt when I was,
you know, 30 years ago when when I first
started on all of this. Yes, so that
must how you chose that road and
historians will
study this, but Sebastian Mallaby is out
with a great book, The Infinity
Machine, and
he said that you spent 30-plus hours,
more than 30 hours with him at a London
pub. I will say that you might be the
first biography in history to spend 30
hours and not regret it, but this book
boils down your choice to you chose to
use your mind, your skills to understand
the universe. Tell us that road taken
and roads that you didn't take.
Yeah, I should say we weren't drinking
in the pub. It was just coffee. So uh
>> [laughter]
>> 30 hours. Um so no, it went fast because
we we actually got on really well and I
mean he I actually wasn't counting the
hours, but he he suggested that and it
was we had a very fun discussion around,
very wide-ranging on all sorts of
topics.
Um and for me the the you know, I
started off on this journey because I've
been always been fascinated by the big
questions in science, the nature of
reality, nature of consciousness, and
I've always been sort of con- almost
puzzled actually that when we go through
life uh
uh most of us we don't really stop to
really ponder those big questions, even
though they're staring us in the face,
you know, like what is time? We don't
know what time is. We have some kind of
hand-wavy idea about it's a direction of
entropy and it's one way, but we don't
really know what it is, which is kind of
astounding to me, let alone gravity,
quantum mechanics, all of these
mysteries. And so I've always been
fascinated by that since I can remember.
And normally when you're fascinated by
those questions, you go into physics.
So, physics was my my favorite subject
at school. But, um I started reading
biographies of all the greats, you know,
my favorites are like Feynman and
obviously Einstein, Weinberg, all of
these types of a brilliant physicist.
And what I realized is that or at least
for me, post-war, post-1970s,
we hadn't really made much progress, in
my opinion, on uh we made a lot of
progress at the beginning of the 1900s.
Uh a like Einstein and Heisenberg and so
on. But, then um towards this latter
part of the of the 20th century, um we
hadn't made that much progress. And I
was kind of wondering why this was, and
I felt that it was like maybe we're
reaching the limit of what the human
mind can comprehend and understand, even
the most brilliant minds, like people
like Feynman, um without the aid of some
new tools.
So, that was my real uh feeling that
that was my kind of takeaway, I suppose,
from reading some of those biographies.
And um
and then combining that with reading a
lot of science fiction, uh Asimov's
Foundation series, Iain Banks's Culture
series, uh and then philosophy books
like Gödel, Escher, Bach, uh which was
very formative for me reading that book.
Um it all kind of came together in that,
well, we could um try and directly
answer some of these questions about
what's the nature of intelligence and
consciousness um by building AI and kind
of comparing it to the human mind, uh
the human brain. But, also it would be a
tool itself that could be used for
science and to advance the frontiers of
what we know. So, um it was sort of
obvious to me 30-plus years ago that
that would be uh uh the most interesting
and perhaps most valuable path forward.
Inspired by the point you made about
biographies,
who's a scientist living working today
who doesn't work for Google who either
should get more attention or you admire
or
future biographies will be written
about.
I mean, there's so many great scientists
out there. Um I I don't know what you
know, if you're asking me who's sort of
underrated, but I do feel like um a lot
of the big biology scientists
uh I mean, they're they're they're
well-known, right? They've won Nobel
Prizes like Paul Nurse and Jennifer
Doudna. These These are amazing
scientists inventing CRISPR, these kinds
of technologies.
Um and I think uh the next generation, I
can't wait to see what they're going to
do with the AI tools and make their own
way and make their own big breakthroughs
with the aid of these amazing uh tools
that we have.
Demis, we're going to finish on a useful
note for the uh builders and future
builders in this room watching around
the world and will watch uh this
conversation in perpetuity. You spend
most of your time in London, but when
you come to the Bay Area,
you feel a palpable builder energy,
which is exciting for all of us when we
visit. A lot of people here are living
and creating that, but you also have a
warning for all of us. You detect a
freneticism.
Yeah, it's amazing energy. When I come I
mean, I spend, you know, about half my
time out here and half in London. It's
uh it's always great to plug into the
energy of the builder and
entrepreneurial ecosystem out here.
Obviously, it's it's second to none, and
it's incredible to see that enthusiasm
and that um
uh
embracing of the kind of the
opportunities. But, I would also say it
you there I do also detect, as you say,
this kind of frenetic uh
rush as well. And I think that that's
not conducive to uh thinking deeply
about hard topics for a long amount of
time. So, I think a lot of the next
advances are going to be in deep tech
um using AI, maybe applying to another
area of hard science. I think there's a
lot of opportunities there, and you're
going to have to go at that for many,
many years um before there's uh a sort
of result. So, I think having some,
sort of, quieter, reflective moments
where you can think very deeply about
what you're planning, not just rushing
with in the in the the the next thing
that you see. The kind of I think a lot
of the times speed is favored over the
the direction. And, um, I'm making sure
you have the direction right is often
more important than just the speed.
Speed is important, velocity is
important, but if you're running, you
know, 100 miles an hour in the wrong
direction, that's actually worse than
standing still and taking a moment to
think about that getting the direction
right. So, I often think there's an
obsession, a bit of an obsession out
here with just velocity, and it's
critical, so I'm not saying that's not
important, but more critical is the the
the the the the direction of that
velocity vector. Very useful. Thank you.
So, at Axios, we always finish with one
fun thing. So, I wanted to ask you about
longevity escape velocity. Uh, the the
idea is if you and I can live five more
years, say, we'll live forever.
How much stock do you put in that
notion, and what are you doing to make
sure that you make it? I I don't really
worry about that kind of question. I'm
very pragmatic when it comes to these
things. So, what I what I'm trying to do
with Isomorphic and what we tried to do
with AlphaFold is use these technologies
to cure terrible diseases.
That's the number one thing I could
think of using AI for. Now, when it
comes to aging, there's I know lots of
aging research and scientists.
Um, there are lots of companies trying
to work on this. There's lots of
theories about what it is. Is it the
culmination of all diseases? Is it a
disease itself? Does it need to be
reprogrammed?
There's a lot of theories out there. Um,
I think that we should start with just
by solving existing terrible diseases we
know about. That will help us live
longer and more healthy lives, and then
let's see what's remaining. Um, and then
we'll take it from there. And what is
your personal health obsession? So, uh,
sometimes you have a whoop, right?
>> yeah. No, well, you know, I try to stay
as healthy as possible while we're in
the in the very few spare minutes I
don't have. I don't sleep enough. That's
one of the main issues I've got to try
and address. What's your average sleep?
>> [laughter]
>> Well, you know, it's I try to get 6
hours, but it's sometimes I fail.
Thank you to Google I/O and Demis
Hassabis. Thanks for an incredible
conversation.
>> Thanks, Mike. Thank you. Thank you.
>> [music]